hello believe nation today I'm going to
share with you the seven greatest
YouTube channels for entrepreneurs all
right so I got asked by one of our
youtube subscribers love you guys
Heath Rodgers who wrote in to say hi
Evan could you make a video on the
greatest YouTube channels for
entrepreneurs so this is my personal
list is my subjective view and what I
think are the seven greatest channels
for you guys to pay attention to I've
categorized it into three different
chunks the first three are gonna be my
absolute favorite the ones I watched
every single video of the ones I feel
our must watch channels for any
entrepreneur the next four are gonna be
situational ones the ones that I watch
some of the videos that come in on them
I pay attention to all of them but I
don't watch every video depends on the
topic and then the last three bonus ones
it's really a top 10 list the last three
bonus ones are gonna be ones that are up
and coming that I'm starting to pay
attention to I haven't made up my mind
on yet and so I wanted to share them
with you but add that little grain of
salt so here we go
so the number one greatest YouTube
channel for entrepreneurs I'm gonna be
subjective here it's my channel if
you're a Kanye West fan you're not a fan
of me you're a fan of yourself you will
believe in yourself
I'm just the expresso I'm just a shot in
the morning to get you going to make you
believe that you can overcome that
situation that you're dealing with all
exam and I want to say this for two
reasons I this can come across as
massively egotistical I want to give you
guys some context I believe that my
channel is one of the greatest channels
not just for entrepreneurs but for
humanity to help people realize their
potential and stop playing small and
start doing things where they can really
be that best version of themselves and
take away my message from it maybe you
don't agree with what I say and I don't
I don't think I'm the greatest speaker
in the world take away me just focus on
the top 10 videos the believe life
videos all of the things that these
great people are saying here's a channel
that every single day pulls in some of
the thoughts from the greatest thinkers
of all time that we are fortunate and
blessed enough to have on this planet
and condenses hours and hours and hours
of footage down into 10 or 20 minutes
for you each time to be able to hang
around the Elon Musk and a Warren
Buffett and Oprah Winfrey and let some
of their knowledge seep in to you I
think it's an amazing gift and so I'm
heavily biased but I have no problem
putting my own channel as the number one
greatest channel for entrepreneurs on
YouTube I think you should be proud of
the work that you're doing
I think whatever you're doing whether
you're a singer or a software developer
or your car manufacturer whatever it is
you should love the work that you're
doing
you should be proud to put your own work
on on the top 10 list yes there may be
people who are doing a great job in
different fields but you know you need
to be proud of the work that you're
doing as well so that's my little humble
brag for the day and hopefully you guys
are enjoying this channel as well
number two for me is Gary Vaynerchuk
he's got a great channel it's a lot of
motivation a lot of inspiration a lot of
tactical things and what to do to run a
business
heavy leaned towards social media and
marketing strategies there but also
about how to build a team and how to
deal with people he's got two series one
is a daily not a daily show a couple
times a week show or it's basically a
call-in show of people emailing him in
and he answers five business questions
and then he also has a vlog series
called daily V where he's just showing
his life and what he's doing why I find
that interesting is one here's a guy
who's had some success you know he has
600 employees I could be off it's around
that number 100 million dollar company
something like that and he's showing his
daily life and he is answering questions
so he was there aren't that many people
who've done what he's done who then
share it right there's so many people
who live behind closed doors but there
aren't a lot of vloggers that you can
follow who built massive businesses
who've done more than you've done I
don't always agree with everything that
he's saying but I like the perspective I
like being able to hang around and like
squeeze out extra juice from someone
who's done more than I have and so I
always find some kind of inspiration and
education in the videos that he puts out
and I usually watch his videos in the
morning while I'm jumping on my
trampoline as a quick workout to work
out my body and work out my mind to and
and so I watch pretty much every video
that comes out on Gary's channel
number three is Lois house he has a
great channel it's called the school of
greatness and it's under his name Lewis
house he brings on people multiple times
per week usually and these guys are not
necessarily just entrepreneurs but but
people have had success you know
greatness people have accomplished big
things and he interviews them and it's
usually about an hour long and what I
love about Louis I think I think there's
really a need for good interviewers I
watch a ton of interviews because of
what we do for our Channel aggregating
content so many interviewers ask boring
questions and then even when the person
gives a great answer there's no
follow-up like you asked a boring
question in a guy like Jobs or Kanye or
you know whoever it is gives a great
answer and then the interviewee that's
the interview were sorry just goes to
the next question because they have a
list of 10 questions and they want to
get through it instead of going deeper
right like Larry King is great at that
Oprah is really great at that but there
aren't a lot of really really good
interviewers which I've discovered by
watching so many interviews Louis is one
of the good guys so this is one of the
greats in my opinion he's he's
up-and-coming he asked some great
questions he asked question that I'm
thinking about and ones that that I
haven't thought of yet and always takes
it a couple layers yeah he has his set
questions and especially ends with the
same questions each time as part of this
ritual but he asks a lot of really great
intriguing inspiring questions and so
you have to be ready to consume it
because his videos are usually about a
lot hour long each time so I'll do it
while I'm doing some other work if I'm
doing some photoshop work or something I
know I'm gonna be at the computer for an
hour so at a time that's gonna watch it
and again I watch pretty much every
single video that Lewis puts out on this
channel and I highly recommend it for
any entrepreneur okay let's get to the
situational ones these are the ones that
I pay attention to every video that they
put out I'm always looking for the title
but I don't watch every video that comes
out so you can you know taste it
yourself and see if it's a fit for you
number four is gonna be Tony Robbins and
I love Tony Robbins I think he produces
amazing content I think he could be
crushing it on YouTube if he had a
better kind of YouTube strategy I'm
looking forward to connecting with him
for my channel and interview and maybe
talking about it too because he's got
such a great message and has some
amazing videos but just isn't enough so
the thing about his channel is that
there's a number of short clips that are
super impactful that I wish for more
long form that you can go deeper with
and then half the videos are also these
kind of testimonials of people who've
had a great experience that are more
selling his whatever course it's coming
up next I don't personally find a lot of
value in those ads they're not hard
sells but it's like journey that
following somebody else's journey
through it I personally don't find a lot
of value in those but I love the
messages that Tony has so I'm basically
always looking to see ok is this from
Tony was this from somebody that he's
helped and if it's from Tony those the
ones that pay attention to and I highly
recommend you guys checking it
number five is charisma on command this
is I think a relatively new China I
don't know how long they've been around
but basically what he does is analyzes
people's charisma who's been doing a lot
around the election because it's a hot
topic right now with Trump versus with
Hillary but he's also done a lot of
other ones and in talking about how
Kevin Hart tells a great story and
talking about how your lessons you can
learn from Game of Thrones on how to
manage people and so I find it really
interesting I like how he breaks things
down because a lot of times you can look
at Kevin Hart someone like Kevin Hart a
comedian and realized he's got so much
to share and he's so funny and and I
watch him and I laugh but you don't know
why what are the things what's the
preparation what are the techniques that
he uses to get that laughter to get
people listening to his stories what
charisma on command does is does a great
job of being able to break those things
down for you so that you're not just
learning through osmosis not just by
being around it by by paying attention
to specific things one thing that really
struck me as an example was with Kevin
Hart he always gets somebody's attention
before he tells the joke so he won't be
off starting the joke until he has
people paying attention so not using the
joke to get the attention having the
attention first and then telling the
joke
so if you want to tell the story you
want to make a speech you want to
communicate whatever message you have
make sure the person's not on their
phone or doing something on the computer
or looking off somewhere else
don't start into the meat of your story
until you have their attention so it's
one of the lessons I learned and I find
that interesting so about half of his
videos are also these breakdowns of
celebrities or comedians or TV shows and
I find those super interesting the other
half are his own personal stories and
those ones I don't resonate with and so
again I'm watching is it about somebody
else that is doing this dissection of or
is it himself talking about his life so
I watch again half and not half and
encourage you to go check it out
number six is tim schmoyer he runs a
great channel called video creators and
this channel really helped me a lot when
I was starting my youtube career I've
been on Tim's channel three times
I think plus part of his series that he
had going on so I love Tim I'm in a
mastermind with him every week he talked
about our channel's huge amount of
respect for him he produces a variety of
content one is around tips and
strategies and how to build a YouTube
channel and the other is around kind of
news and trending things that's happened
on YouTube changes that are being made
where I'm at right now with my channel
you know coming up on half a million
subscribers I find that most of the tips
and strategy stuff are to early stage
for what I'm trying to do but I love the
news and changes that YouTube's making
and more importantly his view on it how
does he think the world is gonna change
YouTube world is gonna change because of
the changes that are being made so I
think if you are trying to build a
YouTube channel if you're not being to
use your charlie probably won't get too
much value here but if you're trying to
build a YouTube channel it's one of the
best places to go and then putting on
your size you leave that watch every
video that's on there or just a
selection of them that fit for you but I
pay attention to every video that he
makes
and number seven for me is Tim Ferriss
this channel this is a love-hate
relationship for me I'm a huge Tim
Ferriss fan a 4-hour work week is one of
my favorite books of all time I picked
up the other books as well he's been a
big influence I mean in terms of
productivity and thinking about my
schedule and how I plan everything out
when he moved to create his podcast so
he has - Tim Ferriss podcast and he puts
those episodes on his YouTube channel as
well does he put on the YouTube channel
I think he does parts of it or maybe I'm
just you're making that up maybe he
doesn't love to check anyway
but anyways a resource worth checking
out I find a lot of his stuff misses for
me I find it's too too technical or too
boring for me and and I'm in the
minority on this because people love his
stuff people consume his podcast like no
tomorrow and it's one of the most
popular ones on the planet so it's just
for me it's not doesn't hit the mark
most of the time but there's always some
that come out that I really like that
one he did one with 20 Robins that was
really great he's done a couple of other
ones that just really hit the mark and
really made me think you know that's
worth it it's worth paying attention to
all the other ones to try to find that
spot so usually with him I'll play the
first couple minutes of it and then see
am I feeling this out or not and then
make a decision whether to listen the
whole thing or not
again it's it's a long form it's usually
about an hour sometimes more of
interviews that he's done and you can
take your pick whether you want to
listen to it or not so those are my top
seven now I wanna share three more these
ones are up-and-coming for me these are
ones that I have subscribed to myself
and I've watched a couple videos on and
and I've been you know taking some stuff
from it it wasn't like insta subscribe
we need to watch every video they've
made but also not you know not hating
them either obviously I'm learning a
little bit from them we're trying to see
are these guys gonna make it into my top
seven list eventually so the first one
is Gary Coxe he has a channel off as his
name and he he's a personal development
guy he helps people try to break through
limiting personal beliefs I'm having him
on my channel actually by the time this
is up Kapali have been on the channel
maybe not we'll see so it's a super
interesting guy and anything about
breaking person beliefs is something
that I'm a big fan of and I would love
to learn more
myselfs which is why i subscribe to him
and so i've watched a couple of his
videos you should a couple times a week
a couple minutes long not not too long
pretty easy to digest and so i'd highly
recommend checking that out if you're
interested in personal development as an
entrepreneur number two is modern health
monk and this one i discovered recently
again he tends to focus he's a younger
guy tends to focus on fitness diet and
productivity
those are his kind of areas and I like
his approach his video style is pretty
easy to understand and digest I've left
some comments on the videos I like his
style
some of the videos hit more than others
for me some of the concepts already
understanding and some of them are new
and different and refreshing so I watch
every video that he's putting out and
I'm on the fence with him put him in the
top seven but he's he has my attention
right now and so I'd recommend checking
in a newer channel getting started but
worth worth a look and number three is
Vox this was recommended to me by Marc
Dreier he's a guy in my mastermind group
I mean I've only been subscribed to them
for a couple days but they had my
attention because of more their editing
style they tend to do a lot of political
kind of stuff they have their own
internal reporters talking about the
history of a conflict or the history of
something which is interesting in a easy
to digest format they tell you that the
long history of something kind of
condensed down into a couple minutes you
get a grasp of what's going on in the
world for the most part I just don't
care and that may sound terrible you
know I don't pay attention to what's
happening in most of the world I'm not a
political science buff I'm not a news
buff I pay attention to entrepreneurs
it was entrepreneurship or salsa or
League of Legends or Blue Jays I'm all
in and everything else I just don't
really pay a lot of attention to I don't
really care too much about the content
what I like about it is the way they
deliver their stories the way they tell
their stories or graphics they use how
simple it is to understand something
they're saying when you have zero
context or background in it I find
fascinating I think anybody who's trying
to learn how to tell a story which you
need to do in the business tell your own
story tell your customers story I think
it's a great channel to be able to learn
and model from so thank you Mark trigger
for that recommendation so that's my
list of the seven greatest YouTube
channels for entrepreneurs with three
extra bonuses of the up-and-coming must
watch and see where they go feature in
there I
- no what do you guys think what are
your favorite channels did I miss
something you know you want to add an
eight nine ten of your own do you
already subscribe to a lot of the
channels that I've already talked about
leave it in the comments let's get some
discussion going and looking forward to
seeing who you guys are paying attention
to so thank you guys for watching thank
you for the question I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're in one word is much
love guys I'll see you soon